[Musica]
buonasera a tutti una platea veramente
bellissima che dirvi voglio partire con
quella che una domanda la domanda che
potrebbe sembrare abbastanza comune di
poco significato ma capiremo poi in
maniera profonda che ha un significato e
il significato è abbastanza profondo
vi siete mai chiesti come un un chirurgo
acquisisce quelle che sono le sue
capacità
fini a livello manuale quella che la
destrezza più fine prima di consegnare
lui quello che se vogliamo il bene più
profondo dell'essere umano la vostra
salute e in alcuni casi la vostra vita è
una domanda che necessita di un
ragionamento sicuramente profondo ma in
particolar modo per capire di cosa sto
parlando e dove voglio arrivare
e importante girarci un po verso il
passato il passato anche non prossimo
infatti parliamo dal xii secolo quindi
dal 1100 fino al 1800 un passato in cui
l'educazione medico chirurgiche era
percepita come un qualcosa di
assolutamente alla torre molto fugace
chelsea la possibilità di diventare
medici clinici o chirurghi ma questi
venivano ad esser formati banalmente con
dei corsi assolutamente non strutturati
non all'interno dell'università di poco
interesse
semmai dopo aver fatto altri lavori come
il come di barbiere l'elemento più
importante però che mi interessa di
questo stralcio di tempo e stralcio di
storia e quello che durante questo
periodo
l'educazione medico chirurgica era
basata su un'azione fondamentale
osservare ci spostiamo poi in un periodo
storico un po più recente quello che va
dal 1800 al 1950
da qui la cosa inizia a diventare molto
più interessante perché come avviene in
in olanda
si iniziano a strutturare quelle che
sono dei liberi propri hub di
condivisione del sapere di tutti quelli
che sono i saperi il sapere tradizionale
inteso come la nozione il saper fare e
il saper essere e quindi il
universitarie diventa lab di
trasmissione di questi saperi dal di dal
maestro che anziano fino al discente
ma ancor più importante la
consapevolezza da parte dello stato che
la salute è un elemento essenziale
pubblico deve essere assolutamente
garantita e quindi strutturare quelli
dei che sono degli esami appunto che
accettava un punto dalla capacità le
nozioni acquisite è di tipo pratico è di
tipo teorico ma assolutamente qualcosa
ancora continua a essere qualcosa di
molto fugace non c'è una vera e propria
struttura non c'è un vero e proprio una
misurazione e concreta di quelli che
sono le capacità da parte del medico
chirurgo ma l'elemento ancor più
interessante anche in questo periodo
storico e quello che il chirurgo
acquisiva le sue competenze in un solo
modo con l'associazione osservando ci
spostiamo poi in quello che il peggiore
invece più prossimo a noi quello che va
dal 1950 ad oggi la tecnologia è
penetrata pervaso qualsiasi e
fattispecie della medicina e quindi
anche quella dell'educazione medico
chirurgica
oggi abbiamo la possibilità di scindere
così come ha fatto il digitale quello
che è il luogo dalla localizzazione io
posso essere posizionato in questo su
questo palco attorno a voi e con un
visore di realtà virtuale quindi con una
tecnologia immersiva osservare quello
che è un campo operatorio che dista a
migliaia di km di distanza oppure
virtualizzare l'intero processo per
facilitare quello che per il discente
l'acquisizione di informazioni ma
abbiamo sempre lo stesso problema
sono passati circa 900 anni e ancora il
concetto la trasmissione
dell'informazione si basa solamente su
un elemento su un'azione osservare c'è
qualcosa che non va c'è qualcosa che non
va è quello che noi ci siamo opposti con
il nostro team come domanda per
rispondere a questa domanda siamo andati
un po a a capire la letteratura che cosa
cosa ci dice in maniera un po più
profondo in maniera un po più
strutturato e dati sono assolutamente
interessanti quanto inquietanti
sì perché secondo gli ultimi dati dati
più recenti noi individuiamo quelli che
sono delle morti per complicanze durante
gli interventi chirurgici che dal 1999
al 2016
son passati solamente negli stati uniti
dal 90 mila unità a 250 mila unità
parliamo quindi di un più 177 per cento
se poi dovessimo presentare quello che
il conto economico finanziarie di quanto
noi stiamo spendendo per questi errori
medici
vediamo ancora che solo negli stati
uniti il costo delle complicanze è
aumentato del 22 per cento dal 2008 al
2012 si è mosso da 17 miliardi di
dollari a 21 circa 20.8 miliardi di
dollari allora ne abbiamo detto c'è
qualche problema all'interno di quello
che è il confronto il processo educativo
fare quello che è il discente e il
maestro l'esperto la trasmissione del
processo dell'informazione e della
capacità di essere chirurgo infatti
abbiamo individuato che le complicanze
tendevano ad essere tre volte maggiori
la probabilità di morte durante un
intervento chirurgico di un giovane
chirurgo sono addirittura cinque volte
superiore le riammissioni sono circa 2.5
volte di più
dovevamo capire e comprendere come
risolvere questo problema abbiamo
cercato di farlo ancora
rientrando all'interno di quella che è
la letteratura scientifica il sapere
scientifico per farlo dobbiamo tornare
all'interno delle cosiddette il curve
quindi curva di apprendimento chiaro la
capacità di individuare in maniera molto
semplice quello che il flusso di
apprendimento di uno studente
ovviamente ci sono delle variabili che
possono essere endogene soldi né come si
vuol dire ma hanno la stessa capacità
ovvero successivamente con il progredire
dal primo intervento chirurgico del
giovane chirurgo procedendo nel tempo
ovviamente quest'ultima acquista
esperienza fino a raggiungere quello che
è un cut off quindi quello che è una
misura che si può rendere definire come
accettabile
ci sono però dei problemi molto
importanti perché gli outcome possono
essere valutati e possono variare molto
in base al re it di apprendimento quindi
la capacità personale di apprendere ma
ancora quelli che la capacità di
scindere dividere saper capire
tra un soggetto che competente un
soggetto esperto qualcosa che può essere
assolutamente sovrapponibile ma non lo è
per forza
e ancora come possiamo individuare
quelli che sono i benchmark ovvero
capire qual è il cut off come lo andiamo
ad individuare sono delle variabili
molto molto complesse però un elemento
importante che ci spiegano appunto le
curve di apprendimento è semplicemente
uno da quando il chirurgo entra per la
prima volta in sala operatoria fino a
quando acquisisce quelle nozioni che
possiamo definire come le nozioni minime
per poter avere una capacità accettabile
in termini prestazionali di performance
possono passare fino a 10 anni e quindi
abbiamo capito che in quello stralcio di
tempo fino a quei dieci anni in cui
aumentano quelli che sono gli outcome
negativi che possono essere clinici
possono essere anche finanziari e
aumento di costi ma anche morti ma anche
la possibilità di avere dei rischi post
operatori molto molto più alti dovevamo
in qualche modo capire come risolvere il
problema la risposta è semplicemente uno
è ancora qui torno alla letteratura
scientifica la simulazione
la simulazione chirurgica ma ancora di
più quello che il processo di
standardizzazione ci siamo mossi allora
verso quelle che sono le società
scientifiche di riferimento
abbiamo cercato di creare partenariati
tale da chiedere loro di creare dei
protocolli scientifici e standardizzati
e di sviluppare poi successivamente
sulla base di questi ultimi dei modelli
di addestramento che avessero due
caratteristiche fondamentali degli hub
based evidence based cioè il valore
individuato come il rapporto fra gli
outcome i costi che deve essere il più
possibile positivo e quindi anche a
livello economico non deve incidere sul
sistema sanitario
lo strumento di addestramento ma in
particolar modo anche evidence based
ovvero tutti gli strumenti devono essere
assolutamente scientificamente basati e
quindi siamo arrivati ad oggi o meglio
siamo nella fase di transizione fra
alloggi e il domani dobbiamo cercare di
creare degli strumenti che abbiamo la
capacità di consentire al chirurgo di
ricevere e quelli che sono i feedback di
strutturare la capacità tattile e quindi
quella che la capacità prensile il gesto
tecnico
un po come quando da piccoli le giovani
bambini imparano
cucire o meglio si faceva come quando si
cucina come quando si inizia ad andare
in bicicletta una successione di
attività che tendono pian piano a
diventare sempre più precise e ci
permettono di ridurre anche quelle che
sono le tempistiche per raggiungere
l'obiettivo dhabi questo è il concetto
che ne abbiamo sviluppato approccio più
che altro si basa però su un modello che
è molto particolare poiché viene ad
essere definito come fi gitano ovvero
l'unione è l'unico modello possibile
finisce il fisico al digitale da una
parte il digitale come abbiamo già detto
precedentemente la capacità di scindere
quello che il luogo della localizzazione
utilizzare del di tutto perché sono
virtuali sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale come vedremo tra poco capaci
di eliminare se vogliamo la presenza
fisica del tutor e utilizzare dei
modelli di auto apprendimento o comunque
strutturare quelle che sono delle
community global che escono fuori dalle
istituzioni dell'università
questo noi lo abbiamo fatto e quello che
vedete accanto a me e alle mie spalle
sono due esempi alla mia destra un
modello fisico associato a quello che
alle mie spalle un modello virtuale un
modello virtuale basato su un po su
quelli che sono le auto se vogliamo
guida autonoma quindi il tracking grazie
degli algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale che ci permette di
individuare le performance su modelli di
apprendimento standardizzati e basati
sull'evidenza sull'evidenza scientifica
ovviamente ne possiamo condividere gli
score con una community digitale che non
esiste più all'interno dell'università o
semplifica ad una decina un centinaio di
soggetti con i quali poi confrontarsi no
andiamo oltre
entrando all'interno di quello che il
mondo assolutamente offline quello che
potete vedere è un sistema validato
scientificamente che ci permette di
educare verso all'interno delle prime
fasi di apprendimento il chirurgo in
chirurgia laparoscopica e quindi un
semplice i peg vengono ad essere
spostati il fine dell'esercizio da
sinistra verso destra ancora una volta
da destra verso sinistra
l'assenza del del tutor ci permette
quindi di ridurre i costi lo abbiamo
fatto
assieme al con un progetto uno dei più
grandi in europa progetto sin base
assieme alla società italiana di
urologia dove abbiamo formato un tutti
gli specialisti futuri specialisti di
specializzati del terzo anno di urologia
tutti contemporaneamente erano
interconnessi e grazie a sistemi di
questo tipo
abbiamo ridotto del 90 per cento i costi
di educazione chirurgica
abbiamo inoltre aumentato quello che è
il pass write
per quanto riguarda il test finale dal
40 al 78 per cento è la cosa più
importante abbiamo ridotto anche quello
che il numero di tutor presenti che
prima per 500 sessioni di addestramento
era pari a 500 tutor con un rapporto uno
a uno
adesso si è ridotto ad un numero pari a
5 questo per noi è il futuro è il
messaggio che vi voglio semplicemente
inviare è che oltre
oggi possiamo fare questo grazie a
sistemi di questo tipo grazie alla
ricerca scientifica oltre
all'osservazione il futuro sarà anche
quello del dell'apprendimento
dell'imparare torniamo nuovamente ad
acquisire il gesto grazie mille
[Applauso]